c'est l'heure de notre second débat
débat vous le savez volontairement
décalé de l'actualité du jour pour vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société ce soir on va
parler de l'emploi des seniors à quoi ça
sert de reculer l'âge de la retraite à
65 ans si à peine 35 % des 60 64 travail
encore que valent les propositions du
gouvernement avant de donner la parole à
nos experts je vous propose un portrait
Brigitte 60 ans et l'enchaîne mission
d'intérim et période de chômage depuis
plus d'une décennie et elle n'a pas de
travail depuis un an Gaspard flamand est
à Libourne
après avoir été responsable dans un
restaurant Brigitte 60 ans est au
chômage depuis 11 ans et enchaîne les
contrats courts alors ça peut être de la
peut être de l'accueil en mairie de la
vente en magasin
alimentaire mais cela va faire un an
qu'elle n'a pas travaillé elle devait
s'occuper de sa mère atteinte de la
maladie d'Alzheimer suite à cette
période Brigitte et classée en catégorie
A par Pôle Emploi selon la définition
elle doit être à la recherche d'un
emploi quel que soit le type de contrat
qu'on trouve pas toujours des emplois
qui nous correspondent ou qui nous
plaisent donc on accepte des travaux qui
sont peut-être plus difficiles à notre
âge parce que très physique mais ça nous
permet de continuer dans dans nos droits
au chômage que le fait de d'être obligé
de d'enchaîner des contrats courts fait
que les les employeurs qui seraient
susceptibles de nous employer dans des
contrats longs n'arrivent pas à nous
faire confiance du fait que on n'a pas
acquis suffisamment d'expérience dans
chaque contrat court alors tous les
jours c'est la même routine elle regarde
les offres disponibles autour de chez
elle qui ne lui correspondent pas
toujours en fait il faut il faut être
apte
l'aéroport de charges lourdes et ben là
ça va pas pouvoir le faire je vais pas
pouvoir postuler à ce type de ce type
d'offre ils acceptent les débutants moi
je ne suis pas débutante mais je suis
pas apte à porter des charges lourdes
voilà
souvent nous fait miroiter des
formations et souvent il y a des
formations mais qui sont pas du tout à
la hauteur de ce que de ce que l'on
espère ou qui sont faites par des
organismes plus ou moins scrupuleux donc
en fait au final
ça jamais vraiment vraiment bien
fonctionner sur le sujet de l'emploi des
seniors le gouvernement propose une
solution réduire la durée
d'indemnisation des chômeurs de plus de
50/50 afin d'assiter les entreprises à
embaucher des seniors mais pour Brigitte
le problème est ailleurs continué de
travailler pour avoir une retraite à
taux plein enfin moi ça va pas me
pénaliser de toute façon j'ai encore
beaucoup de temps à faire mais la
difficulté c'est quel emploi qu'est-ce
que je vais trouver comme emploi qui
soit encore que je sois encore capable
de faire physiquement et qui me permet
de continuer jusqu'à la retraite c'est
ça quel emploi
selon un rapport ministériel d'avril
2022 le taux d'emploi est de 75 % chez
les 50 550 9 ans il chute à 35% chez les
60 ans
l'emploi des seniors on en débat tout de
suite avec Anne-Marie Guimard bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur émérite à
l'Université Paris Cité membre du Centre
d'études des mouvements
sociaux EHS membres qualifié du Conseil
du Haut Conseil de la famille de
l'enfance et de l'âge et je vais citer
l'un de vos livres allongement de la vie
quel défi quelle politique publié aux
éditions La Découverte un lit Jolivet
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes économiste
chercheuse au Centre d'études de
l'emploi et du travail au CNAM Benoît
service président bonsoir bienvenue
vice-président de l'Association
nationale des directeurs des ressources
humaines et puis avec nous en duplex en
visioconférence Stéphanie Lecerf qui est
président de l'association à compétences
égales bonsoir bienvenue associations
qui regroupe des professionnels des
Ressources Humaines vous coachez voilà
des candidats quel que soit leur âge et
donc notamment des des seniors Mathieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés je vais commencer par don de poser
une question mais vraiment ultra basique
c'est quoi un senior Anne-Marie
il commence à quel âge et la réponse est
peut-être pas si simple non c'est une
mauvaise question excusez-moi
parce que en fait ça n'a plus de sens
pas plus d'ailleurs qu'un âge légal de
la retraite aujourd'hui pourquoi parce
que chacun aujourd'hui dans une
situation de société de longévité
chacun a des parcours différenciés donc
si on disons en 45 ou dans les années 60
en pleine période de la société
industrielle on avait à peu près à une
vie à trois temps il y avait une
formation
la vie de travail qui durait 50 ans à
l'époque et la retraite mais aujourd'hui
on peut plus décrire avec la retraite à
65 ans avec une espérance de vie à la
retraite de quelques années
voilà donc on a complètement changé de
monde avec l'allongement de la vie les
sont extrêmement différenciés donc si
vous prenez un seigneur de 50 ans il
peut être avec
les enfants établis
etc
et donc être dans une stratégie
différente de du même homme de 50 ans
qui sera en parentalité tardive qui aura
des jeunes enfants et qui aura pas la
même stratégie envers la retraite que
que l'autre donc ça n'a pas de sens de
parler d'âge et c'est tout dépend de ce
qu'on a fait comme parcours
professionnel antérieure
mais est-ce qu'il y a une définition
officielle ou pas dans les dans les
statistiques d'ailleurs ou peut-être pas
d'ailleurs c'est à se comprendre comme
convention c'est que on part à 55 ans et
jusqu'à 64 c'était à peu près le champ
qu'on s'était fixé depuis le début des
années 2000 avec la stratégie européenne
pour l'emploi et les objectifs les
premiers objectifs sur le taux d'emploi
des seniors mais ce ne sont que des
conventions statistiques donc en fait
quand on descend par exemple au niveau
des entreprises dire à quelqu'un il est
senior parce qu'il a passé 55 ans ça n'a
pas plus de sens que c'est la même chose
en termes d'usure professionnelle par
exemple ou de ou de parcours
professionnel le seuil qui peut être
pertinent pour une entreprise ça peut
très bien être 48 ça peut très bien que
ça dépend de la pénibilité de de du
travail
cours dans l'entreprise est-ce que les
gens partent ou pas à quel moment
éventuellement il quitte une activité
qu'ils ont pu garder pendant plusieurs
années donc c'est vraiment dès qu'on
descend à niveau d'entreprise ou de
secteur faut vraiment avoir des éléments
beaucoup plus fins pour apprécier un âge
éventuellement basculement
un troisième âge c'est globalement les
entreprises les gens vous disent en
essayant à 45 ans
parce qu'en fait on est incapable de
dire seulement il y a tout un tas de
choses qui se passent à 45 ans reçoit
des obligations on doit les publier dans
les rapports sociaux ce qui fait que il
y a jamais une loi qui a dit on est
seniors à 45 ans mais en revanche il y a
tout un tas de trucs qui sont mis en
place qui fait finalement que la 45 ans
vous commencez à recevoir des courriers
comme vous êtes seniors vous devez avoir
un entretien machin entretien ceci cela
c'est absolument dramatique ça c'est
d'abord
on commence à vous-même
on est bien d'accord donc donc ça veut
dire même dans l'état d'esprit général
est-ce que ça provoque toujours content
d'entendre une jolie mais il y a le
sujet c'est on sait que le problème il
se pose à 55
vraiment sur l'emploi il se pose assez
peu avant alors je suis d'accord avec
vous on différencie des métiers des
compétences et parcours mais
fondamentalement au global les problèmes
se posent vraiment à partir de 55 et
pourtant aller dans n'importe quelle
entreprise Vous demandez aux gens ils
disent bah moi j'ai appris que j'étais
seniors à 45 ans c'est un côté un peu
désespérant bien sûr et on va poser la
question justement à Stéphanie lecer
parce que c'est ce que c'est ce que vous
faites au quotidien dans dans votre
association il faut imaginer
une un rendez-vous de recrutement avec
un recruteur d'un côté peut-être
trentenaire allez et puis un candidat de
l'autre qui a
51-52 ils ont pas et tout à fait la même
vision du mot senior c'est ça oui ils
ont pas exactement la même perception
c'est vrai qu'on les a interrogés sur la
manière dont il perçoivent le mot senior
et à quel âge on est seniors ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que il y a une
petite différence de perception les
candidats perçoivent plutôt seniors
autour de 53 ans là où les recruteurs ou
les entreprises les percevraient seniors
plutôt autour de
devant donc on s'accorde à tourner
autour de 50 ans je rejoins totalement
Benoît serres dans les entreprises
aujourd'hui on est en deuxième partie de
carrière à partir de 45 ans il y a une
notion qui s'ajoute et qui est très
intéressante c'est que je rejoins tout
ce qui a été dit il y a des différences
très importantes de perception et
notamment on va être plus perçu senior
quand on va être finalement à 45 ans au
bout d'une expérience unique de 20 ans
dans la même entreprise que quand on
aura multiplié les expériences et qu'on
aura acquis un certain nombre
d'expériences professionnelles
différentes qui se sont additionnés donc
ce côté mono-expérience vient accroître
la notion de Seigneur en entreprise et
vient renforcer l'impression de
seniorité alors je redonne un chiffre
qu'on a entendu dans dans le sujet tout
à l'heure de Gaspard flamand
35,5% des 60 64 ans
occupaient un poste la source et le
rapport du Conseil d'or des retraites et
c'est pas beaucoup mieux si on si on
revient à ce à cet âge des 55 c'est pour
les 55 64 ans on est un taux d'emploi
qui atteint péniblement les
56%. je voudrais savoir maintenant
comment ça se passe chez nos voisins
européens et j'appelle Quentin Calmet
qui doit être juste là derrière le
rideau bonsoir rebonsoir Quentin alors
ce taux d'emploi des seniors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en dire en Europe chez nos
voisins et bien effectivement il varie
entre 77% en Suède et 43% en Roumanie
alors je vais tout de suite donner
quelle est la barre que j'ai choisi ce
que vu que c'était un des éléments du
débat j'ai regardé le taux de personnes
actives dans le total de la population
de la tranche d'âge 55 64 ans qui est
voilà le l'outil qu'utilise eurostats
donc c'est celui que j'ai conservé donc
dans le haut du classement on voit qu'au
dessus de 70% il y a la Suède la Norvège
et le Danemark il y a d'autres pays qui
sont 10 points au dessus de la moyenne
de l'Union européenne l'Allemagne à 71%
Pays-Bas Finlande donc tous autour de
70%
de taux d'emploi d'autres pays qui sont
autour de cette moyenne européenne on va
la voir et en cette moyenne elle est de
60,5% pour l'ensemble des 27 de l'Union
européenne donc le Portugal et l'Irlande
qui sont autour de cette moyenne voilà
la France qui arrive donc plutôt vers le
bas du classement d'où ce titre emploi
des seigneurs la France mauvaise élève
car on se situe à 56% effectivement mais
d'autres pays d'Europe sont encore plus
bas on pense à la Grèce au Luxembourg et
à la Roumanie qui ferme ce classement
avec seulement 43% alors dans un rapport
sénatorial et les parlementaires font le
lien entre l'âge légal et ce taux
d'emploi des seniors voilà l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite effectivement
pardon mais effectivement c'est le
rapport le plus récent que j'ai pu
trouver au sénate de 2019 et vous allez
le voir les sénateurs ils ont comparé
les législations sur cette tâche de
départ à la retraite avec le taux
d'emploi il note vous le voyez que les
pays où l'âge de départ à la retraite et
le plus élevé le taux d'emploi des 60 64
ans et le plus élevé aussi et ça c'est
pour l'échelle l'OCDE dans leur rapport
autre information que j'ai trouvé
intéressante dans ce rapport sénatorial
et bien ça concerne la France les on a
pu lire comme ça des actifs qui
prenaient tout juste leur retraite qui
ont été interrogés et lorsqu'ils sont
interrogés effectivement dans une étude
et bien ces actifs qui partent à la
retraite ils disent que bien le fait
d'atteindre l'âge limite de départ à la
retraite c'est ce qui fait aussi qui
partent à la retraite d'où cette
conclusion du rapport il y a un rôle
prescripteur joué par les bornes d'âge
dans notre système de retraite en clair
selon les sénateurs les actifs
choisissent de partir à la retraite dès
qu'ils ont atteint l'âge légal tu as
marqué merci beaucoup Quentin est-ce que
ça veut dire Anne-Marie Guimard que sur
prolonge si on recule l'âge de la
retraite on va forcément
améliorer ce taux d'emploi des seniors
certainement non d'ailleurs pourquoi
vous savez parler des des 55 64 ans en
taux d'emploi mais ce qui serait
intéressant c'est de regarder les 60 64
ans parce que j'ai donné le chiffre
aussi c'est 35 et quelques 35,5 %. oui
mais alors là on est vraiment lanterne
rouge parce que
la moyenne de l'OCDE c'est 45% ou
quelque chose comme ça donc assez loin
et
et on est à 70% pour la Suède à 70%
pour
d'autres pays enfin bon on a des on a
des écarts considérables donc prenons
ces 60 64 ans
le problème est je prendrai un rapport
enfin un travail du corps
début 2022 il montre très bien que l'âge
de sortie du marché du travail et en
France
plutôt de deux ans
par rapport à l'âge de liquidation de la
retraite donc vous avez
les personnes il y a une disjonction qui
est assez qui est un cas particulier
français en général vous avez une
conjonction les gens sortent du marché
du travail et
liquide leur retraite mais en France
vous avez un temps assez long de deux
ans et ce temps long donc ça veut dire
de virer avant ou après
de pouvoir faire la jonction avec ta
retraite
fait une poche de précarité en fin de
carrière pour une partie importante
de la population des seniors
l'émission toujours le corps le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites je disais
que on a progressé sur ce taux d'emploi
des des 60 64 ans notamment dans la
dernière décennie entre 60 et 62 ans
grâce à quoi
il y a un mélange de yamanoche de choses
il y a alors premier truc auquel on va
penser c'est les réformes des retraites
successives et puis les années 90 mais
il y a aussi la suppression des prières
traites publiques qui a quand même
beaucoup joué y compris pour modifier
l'appétence des entreprises à faire
partir assez tôt
les gens les plus les plus âgés et puis
il y a aussi toute une série de
modifications comme par exemple le
relèvement de l'âge de mise à la
retraite le fait que ça bascule plutôt à
l'initiative du salarié d'autres
dispositifs qui permettent de partir
comme les ruptures conventionnelles et
puis il y a aussi toute la réforme les
réformes de l'assurance chômage depuis
2002 un peu avant 2002 qui ont beaucoup
modifié les conditions d'indemnisation
mais ça n'a pas encore changé d'un point
de vue culturel et c'est vrai qu'on a
été je vais dire perfusé au pré retraite
pendant des années dans une période de
chômage de masse qui ont fait que des
employeurs ont fait des arbitrages pour
faire partir plutôt les salariés qui
coûtent leur coûter les plus chers
ingénieurs et qui selon une productivité
qui était moindre et ça s'est inscrit
quand même dans les mentalités donc oui
les gens restent en poste mais est-ce
que les seniors sont mieux formés qui
est aujourd'hui à part il était une
époque où à partir de 45 ans en forme
plus les salariés parce qu'on se dit ça
sert pas à grand chose de toute façon
dans 10 ans je le débarque c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça qu'on qu'on
réfléchissait est-ce que ça ça a changé
je crois qu'un petit peu mais on n'est
pas encore sur des chiffres équivalents
entre les gens moins de 45 ans et ce
plus de 45 ans ensuite il y a quelle
nature de Job occupe ces seniors on l'a
vu dans votre reportage
initial c'est quand même une femme oui
qui est considérée comme une Seigneur au
travail mais qui cumule de l'intérim des
petit jobs dans certains exemples que
vous avez montré à l'étranger notamment
l'Allemagne il y a aussi ce qu'on
appelait des mini jobs pour des pour des
gens qui étaient un âge ou d'autres
prennent leur retraite dans d'autres
pays et puis enfin moi ce qui me frappe
c'est toujours dans cette culturellement
il y a il y a un double standard au fond
quand vous êtes dirigeant l'entreprise
ça ne pose jamais aucun souci on parle
d'homme d'expérience on parle jamais de
seniors la moyenne des patrons du CAC 40
augmenter on est aujourd'hui entre 57 58
ans il y a pas de souci pour ces gens-là
on se dit pas il faut les ranger la
voiture dans 6 ans ils sont débarqués
ils sont plus à la page ils sont plus
productifs non jamais en revanche pour
tous les autres on a encore cette ses
lunettes qu'il faut arriver à qu'il faut
arriver à changer est-ce que ça est-ce
que ça évolue quand même de un petit à
petit au sein des entreprises moi je
partage de points sur le fait qu'il y a
il y a un vrai sujet culturel depuis des
années et qu'on arrive pas à casser le
mouvement je pense qu'il y a aujourd'hui
une meilleure capacité des entreprises
insuffisante à conserver les seniors en
revanche on n'arrive pas à craquer un
point qui est de les embaucher c'est ça
le problème en fait garder les seniors
on vous avait rappelé très bien d'abord
il y a des dispositifs pour les
conserver qui sont un peu réservés aux
grandes boîtes quand même vous savez les
fameux congés de fin de carrière
qui permettent en fait d'accompagner
quelqu'un jusqu'à son taux plein on va
dire sans pour il reste à l'entreprise
mais il est pas un peu moins cher en
100% pour ça donc il y a des dispositifs
qui sont plutôt malins parce qu'on a
beaucoup de gens qui les demandent et là
vous avez raison en revanche elles sont
totalement inatteignables pour les
petites boîtes donc ça c'est sans doute
quelque chose à voir
en revanche
la capacité à embaucher
elle est très difficile au delà de 57 58
mais donc ça veut dire que si on perd
son emploi après 55
mais c'est compliqué 57 je dirais ça
devient très difficile et là les
entreprises ont une forme de culpabilité
je j'avoue complètement tout simplement
parce que vous avez deux causes en fait
la première cause c'est se dire la
personne elle a quand même déjà 25 ans
30 ans de carrière ça se trouve elle l'a
fait dans la même voie donc le temps
qu'on la réadapte la culture entreprise
on va avoir du mal vrai ou pas vrai mais
en tout cas c'est le raisonnement et
après vous avez beaucoup de managers
recruteurs qui disent non tu peux pas
mettre quelqu'un qui a 20 ans de moins
plus que moi etc donc il y a un frein
pardon la question du salaire en fait ça
c'est pas vrai
j'entends partout j'ai vu des rapports
de Olivier du socle de cumulus de
compenser avec une indemnité la perte de
salaire en détail
ça c'est un c'est une fake news cette
histoire là moi je les seniors vous dise
attendez moi je veux bien je comprends
accepter un peu moins de rémunération
qu'avant c'est un vrai c'est une un vrai
faux débat ça d'accord ça arrange tout
le monde de dire ça mais c'est pas c'est
pas exact c'est pas exact après ce dont
vous parliez c'est-à-dire faire partir
des gens plus âgés pour entrer en plus
jeune on râle c'est une technique pas
très glorieuse mais qui s'appelle
l'effet de noria c'est-à-dire que vous
bénéficiez de l'écart mais ça ça se fait
généralement dans des plans qui sont de
plus en plus grâce aux ordonnances de
2017 d'ailleurs des plans volontaires
alors je voudrais donner la parole à
Stéphanie Auxerre là-dessus sur sur le
ce que vous nous dites c'est une fake
news c'est une idée reçue le fait que
quand on hésite à embaucher un seigneur
la question du salaire est-ce qu'elle
rentre ou pas en ligne de compte d'après
vous de votre expérience
alors elle continue à rentrer en ligne
de compte dans le sens où ça vient pas
des seniors les seniors et dans une
étude qu'on a mené récemment 10 majorité
qui sont prêts à réduire leur salaire
ils sont prêts à immobile
géographiquement ils sont même
intéressés par le fait de prendre
d'autres rôles ou d'autres
responsabilités on a vraiment
aujourd'hui
des personnes qui sont expérimentées qui
ont d'autres aspirations en deuxième
partie de carrière par contre les
entreprises elles ont de plus en plus
elles ont beaucoup de difficultés à
intégrer ça on a quand même en France le
mythe de la carrière ascendante on a le
sentiment que plus on avance dans sa
carrière plus on va vouloir un salaire
qui progresse et finalement là où les
managers sont un peu frileux c'est que
quand ils voient des seniors baisser
leur niveau de rémunération ils se
disent bon bah c'est quelqu'un qui va
pas rester en poste à la première
occasion venue il va partir pour une
autre ange ou alors s'il accepte un
salaire qui est plus bas c'est qu'il est
dans une forme d'échec par rapport à sa
carrière professionnelle ou alors elle
va essayer de vouloir mon poste mais
c'est vrai que ça entretient encore un
certain nombre de stéréotypes donc même
si en tant que tel c'est pas la première
raison ça peut être évoqué par contre
c'est vrai que ça a reculé et
aujourd'hui les raisons qui sont plus
évoquées par les entreprises ou par les
recruteurs c'est ce qui a déjà été
mentionné la difficulté d'intégrer des
personnes plus seniors dans l'entreprise
avec des managers plus jeunes on a un
vrai gros problème de culture en France
par rapport aux autres pays européens
le sentiment aussi avec toute cette
émergence du digital qu'on aurait des
seniors qui seraient moins
sensibles ou moins familier avec toutes
ces techniques alors ça fait déjà plus
de 10 ans qu'on est on a l'expérience
sur le sujet
malgré tout c'est vrai que les
formations elles leur sont moins
proposées donc on alimente aussi un
petit peu ces stéréotypes à cause de de
ce manque de maintien de l'employabilité
par les entreprises alors et donc enfin
est-ce que le ce que je j'appuie
totalement c'est qu'il y a eu beaucoup
l'effort de fait sur le maintien dans
l'emploi mais que ça s'est fait beaucoup
au détriment du recrutement il faut
savoir qu'à un moment on donnait le
choix aux entreprises de faire soit du
maintien dans l'emploi soit du
recrutement et que en grande majorité
elles ont choisi maintenant dans
l'emploi quand même alors je reste sur
cette question du salaire je vous
propose de voir les principales
propositions du ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft pour essayer de voilà de
trouver des solutions à ce très bas taux
d'emploi des des 60 64 ans en France
réduire la d'indemnisation des chômeurs
de plus de 55 ans indemnisé on en
parlait d'une certaine façon les plus de
55 ans qui acceptent un emploi moins
bien payé compléter les revenus des plus
de 60 ans à temps partiel avec une
fraction de leur pension et enfin créer
un index senior pour noter les
entreprises je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait
grand monde pour défendre ses
propositions autour de cet arbre mais on
va voir je reste sur cette histoire de
de salaire Anne-Marie Guillemard
indemnise et les plus de 50/50 qui
acceptent un job moins bien payé vous
n'y êtes pas favorable pourquoi je pense
que on reste
on souffre en France une vision
très négative du vieillissement au
travail et
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va l'arranger
je me souviens du plan emploi senior
2006-2010 ou la mesure phare de ce plan
c'était un CDD senior il n'y a pas eu
plus de dizaine de signatures d'un CDD
Seigneur ça correspondait pas du tout à
ce que les entreprises ce dont les
entreprises avaient besoin donc on reste
dans les mêmes choses c'est qu'il faut
faire pour moi c'est pas réformer l'âge
de la retraite parce qu'on l'a déjà fait
assez souvent je crois et c'est très
bien 62 ans mais on peut avoir ce que le
président Macron avait proposé dans un
premier quinquennat qui était le la
retraite à la carte pouvait partir quand
on voulait je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus adapté à une société de longévité
donc où on a pris l'habitude de gérer
son parcours et d'avoir une certaine
souveraineté sur son parcours donc
pour la mesure en question je pense que
ce qu'il faut c'est ouvrir un horizon en
emploi en emploi on est braqué en France
sur l'horizon de la retraite qu'il faut
repousser pour moi c'est c'est une
mauvaise stratégie la stratégie pour
réduire le problème des 60 60 ans et
faire remonter le taux d'emploi c'est de
leur ouvrir des horizons en emploi vous
parlez la formation dont on parlait la
formation
après 45 ans de fin de carrière
attractive ça veut dire justement pour
les entreprises de réfléchir à des
parcours de fin de carrière plus
horizontaux où se pose pas le problème
de l'augmentation de salaire mais plus
un problème de peut-être mais mieux
maîtriser son temps moins de contrats de
temporaire et des choses comme ça donc
c'est au niveau de ouvrir un horizon en
emploi il n'en n'ont pas ils sont
obligés de partir sur cette mesure ce
que vous en pensez les uns et les hôtels
je vivais je conseille vous donc je
rappelle indemniser les plus de 55 ans
qui accepte un emploi moins bien payé
donc j'en déduis qu'on parle de
demandeur d'emploi qui sont inscrits à
Pôle Emploi
pourquoi enfin moi je suis pas opposé à
ce genre de de mais je vois pas pourquoi
ça serait uniquement les 60 ans et plus
à la limite quelqu'un qui reprend un
emploi on pourrait très bien avoir une
phase de transition quand il y a
vraiment une descente de salaire et par
ailleurs il y a déjà eu cette
possibilité quand vous demander en
emploi vous pouvez reprendre une
activité
occasionnelle ou réduite et vous avez la
possibilité qui a été en plus un peu
assouplie récemment de voilà vous avez
pas de tellement de conditions qui
s'appliquent donc en fait je suis pas
sûr qu'on ait besoin d'avoir une
disposition sur ne pas le réserver au
plus de 55 ou au plus de 60 c'est une
forme de baptisation entre guillemets
parce qu'en fait le problème d'une
mobilité professionnelle où on va par
exemple ailleurs sur un autre territoire
ou un accepte d'aller dans une
entreprise qui peut être plus
intéressante mais qui est moins ou les
salaires sont moins élevés c'est qu'on
peut avoir un souci pour décrocher d'un
niveau de salaire plus élevé il faut un
temps d'adaptation donc je vois pas
pourquoi ce serait quelque chose de
particulièrement réservé
sur cette proposition
comment on sait que c'est pas forcément
ça qui coince je suis pas sûr que c'est
ça qui va régler le problème ça peut
être dans un paquet pourquoi pas ça peut
être utile il faut faire attention aux
effets d'aubaine parce que
de certains syndicats c'est de dire ça
va permettre au patron de payer moins
cher bon c'est toujours pareil
peut-être qu'il faut réserver parce que
le sujet de l'emploi alors des seniors
ou pelage
globalement dans les grandes entreprises
on y arrive à peu près en revanche il y
a un vrai soleil des PME et le tissu
d'emploi et je pense que ça c'est une
mesure intéressante à réserver le
deuxième point je partage 1000% votre
point de vue il y a des entreprises des
grandes entreprises très connues qui le
font dire qu'ils mettent en place des
temps partiels seniors qui amènent
autant de travail qui font énormément de
gens qui le font pourquoi mais parce que
ce sont des grandes entreprises qui ont
les moyens et le sujet c'est que quand
vous discutez alors c'est clair je
réunit beaucoup beaucoup de DH de toutes
les tailles donc on discute pas mal de
sujets et puis on va parler l'index
Seigneur tout à l'heure parce que
j'étais l'auteur de la proposition
initiale donc je connais bien mais
pas comme c'est présenté
[Musique]
il faut absolument en revanche rétablir
l'équilibre entre les capacités des PME
et TPE à maintenir le Seigneur les
capacités connues des grandes
entreprises parce que ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait une mesure ciblée sur les TPE
tout à l'heure c'est que moi je pense
que la question de l'emploi des seniors
ce mot m'énerve à force mais c'est un
vrai sujet sociétal en fait dire qu'on
est en train de fabriquer toute une
génération non seulement de seniors
finalement pauvre en fin de carrière et
vu les réformes des retraites ça va pas
s'arranger avec avec leur pension et ça
c'est extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'avec la longévité vous êtes une
grande spécialiste on sait que ces gens
là moi j'en ai plein dans l'entreprise
qui ont une 60 ans mais ils sont aidants
de leurs parents et ils soutiennent
leurs propres enfants donc en eux
perdent leur emploi c'est un drame sur
trois générations c'est pour ça que on
est intervenu assez tôt ce sujet dès
2018 pour dire ok c'est peut-être un
problème financier de boulot de culture
comme vous le dites c'est surtout un
problème de société et que si on
l'adresse pas très vite on va avoir des
vrais vrais difficultés d'ordre social
et sociétal et ça c'est vraiment le job
de l'État d'éviter ce genre de dérive
Olivet le regard global que vous
proposez on va les revoir les les que
vous jetez sur des propositions du
gouvernement je les ai cités en détail
tout à l'heure Annie Jolivet c'est donc
réduire la durée ce dont on parle
indemnisation l'index seniors on va y
venir dans un instant le complet de
revenus pour les plus de 60 ans à temps
partiel vous dites quoi vous dites c'est
pas un plan suffisamment ambitieux c'est
c'est quoi le regard que vous pour être
un peu cash je dirais je trouve c'est un
peu démesurétiens c'est à dire je vois
pas bien l'intérêt je vois pas ce qu'il
y a comme vision derrière et je trouve
qu'on passe à côté de
je suis d'accord il y a un problème
sociétal mais il y a aussi un problème
sociétal dans les entreprises et
d'ailleurs pas que dans les entreprises
dans les administrations les
organisations c'est pas un sujet qui est
uniquement pour le secteur privé
la vraie question c'est c'est comment on
travaille comment on s'organise comment
on évolue dans ces façons de travailler
avec par exemple le digital des
nouvelles activités je trouve que il y a
un vrai souci sur le management sur les
conditions de travail et en fait se
débarrasser des seniors ou ou mettre un
peu l'accent sur eux c'est aussi une
façon de d'évacuer la question en fait
on a mis en place des formations pour
les jeunes des formations techniques etc
et finalement on s'est désintéressé des
seniors pas parce qu'on voulait les
exclure on va pas systématiquement mais
tout simplement parce qu'on y fait pas
attention on regarde pas ce qui ce qui
est de l'ordre de l'expérience ce que
quels sont les apports de compétences
qu'on peut avoir et comment on
entretient ça au fil de la carrière et
ça c'est pas une question qui qui se
pose à 55 ans mais ça c'est le regard
global de notre société sur les vieux et
le fait le simple fait que de dire ce
mot c'est déjà un tabou enfin moi je me
souviens d'avoir été dans des
entreprises pour faire des des études
sur les plans d'action seniors et les
accords on avait quand même des
entreprises qui nous disaient mais nous
mais nous on n'a pas de problème seniors
nous on regarde pas les seniors dans
notre entreprise on s'occupe de tout le
monde et quand on prend des mesures
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
elles sont pour tout le monde on discute
de l'organisation du travail et agir
pour améliorer la situation c'est pas
forcément agir le seul Seigneur qui est
dans l'équipe ça peut être configuré
l'organisation du travail voire même au
niveau plus général entre services et ça
peut changer énormément de choses sur la
pression la charge mentale l'usure
physique et du coup le souhaite partir
plus tôt parce qu'on en a pas parlé mais
le souhaite partir plus tôt il est quand
même très lié au sens qu'on a de son
travail mais aussi au fait d'être
reconnu et puis il y a un facteur qui
sort beaucoup c'est ce être en capacité
d'apprendre dans son travail voilà quand
on est dans un travail monotone qu'en
plus on a eu un parcouragé
éventuellement à temps partiel on n'a
pas envie de rester et toutes les
options qu'on peut proposer même être
avoir des pensions plus élevées c'est
pas forcément ça qui va faire rester par
contre les gens qui disent je veux
rester après l'âge de la retraite c'est
ceux qui disent je me sens reconnue dans
mon travail mon travail est intéressant
et j'apprends oui donc il y a vraiment
des choses à travailler à la question
centrale du sens quoi du sens qu'on
donne à des conditions concrètement
effectivement parmi les mesures qu'on a
qu'on a revu cette index senior je vous
propose d'écouter le la réaction Scandi
le président délégué du Medef Patrick
Martin il était sur France Info hier
pourquoi l'index ce nom parce que je
prends un casque caricatural vous créez
une start-up par définition vous n'avez
pas des seniors en tout cas ça sera un
hasard discret quand même 800000
d'entreprise par an donc on peut dire
que quelque soit le secteur d'activité
ce sont des startups et de l'emploi pas
évidemment des salariés et puis par
ailleurs je le redis dans le bilan
social que les entreprises regardent
attentivement avec des partenaires
sociaux on a déjà beaucoup d'indices on
peut les compléter mais travaillons déjà
mieux ce qui existe alors Benoît sert
pour pourquoi fallait-il éventuellement
index seniors et pourquoi celui qui est
proposé là vous convient pas forcément
l'histoire
bien placé ce qui se passe c'est
rapidement en fait en 2018 quand la
président Macron a commencé à annoncer
sa réforme des retraites on est
intervenu très très vite en disant
c'est intéressant parce que on va faire
les formes des retraites dans sa
conférence de presse initiale sur le
sujet je peux ils en souvenez il avait
dit bien sûr qu'il faut régler le
problème des seniors avant et puis très
sa sortie il n'y avait rien donc du coup
on est intervenu et l'autre raison elle
était que je sais pas si vous voulez
c'est l'époque où il y a eu le fameux
index égalité femme homme et on avait
été frappé par le fait que en France on
traitait toutes les discriminations du
monde et c'était très bien mais celle-là
qui était la principale à l'embauche et
tout le monde le savait personne n'en
parlait donc on s'est dit on va puisque
tout le monde les index on avait des
index c'est pas pour le plaisir de
mettre un index c'est ni Patrick Martin
et à la fois vrai et faux c'est à dire
que le sujet de l'index c'est pas
forcément l'index punitif comme on
connaît sur d'autres éléments c'est
simplement s'assurer et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure que le taux d'accès à la
formation il est supérieur à la moyenne
de l'entreprise quand vous avez 50 ans
parce que ça ne prépare pas sinon
l'intérêt de l'index est s’assurer que
les entreprises pour certaines le font
d'autres le font pas c'est suivre le
fait qu'on n'est pas en train de
reproduire le passé donc
aujourd'hui à partir de 45 ans propose
plus de formation salariés et donc là au
contraire il faudrait donc je plus de
formation pour les pour les plus de 50
ans de responsabilité c'est l'intérêt
d'un index vous suivez par exemple le
taux d'accès la formation le taux
immobilier professionnelle le taux de
référentiel de compétences on peut le
faire aujourd'hui ça et puis de l'autre
côté l'État doit soutenir on a proposé
très vite par exemple de doubler le
fameux compte personnel de formation
vous savez pour les gens à partir de 50
ans pour justement préparer une partie
de carrière sinon on ne fera que
reproduire ce qu'on connaît parce que
comme vous l'avez très justement dit la
question est très culturelle et on sait
que ça va pas se régler avec un texte de
loi en revanche si on suit ces questions
là beaucoup plus précisément comme on
l'a fait dans d'autres populations alors
on arrêtera cette espèce d'atomisation
on a réglé assez fortement le problème
des jeunes par le fameux plan un jeu
d'une solution je dis pas qu'il faut
faire un plan un vieux une solution mais
c'est la même méthode comme ça mais
c'est pas terrible mais
voilà c'est qu'il faut une politique
volontariste des entreprises qui emporte
leur responsabilité et une entreprise
une politique volontariste de l'État
pour corriger ou est-ce qu'on en est et
puis qu'on en a retrouvé une situation à
peu près normale dans la moyenne
européenne on reprendra comme vous le
dites le rythme normal mais il faut
casser la logique sinon ça va durer des
années cette histoire Stéphanie lecer
vous publiez avec Lipsos régulièrement
un baromètre d'accès à l'emploi donc là
il y a eu le baromètre de 2022 qu'est-ce
qui en ressort sur ces finalement ce
dont on parle les freins à l'embauche
des seniors parce qu'on a bien compris
on réussit les entreprises ont progressé
réussissent à les garder plus longtemps
en revanche quand il s'agit d'un
embaucher un ça marche pas
mais sur les frais à l'embauche c'est ce
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure celui qui
ressort le plus
de la part des recruteurs en tout cas
c'est la difficulté d'intégration dans
des équipes plus jeunes donc c'est une
manière de dire que ce frein il est
avant tout culturel le deuxième frein
qui ressort c'est vraiment l'impression
qu'il y a une faible adaptation aux
nouvelles technologies et que de fait un
senior n'a pas être capable de s'adapter
à l'entreprise vous êtes en train pardon
c'est c'est de ma faute parce que en
fait la question amène une réponse qui
est un peu similaire à la précédente
mais qu'est-ce que vous vous parce que
vous faites des propositions aussi
qu'est-ce que vous vous proposez pour
nous faire progresser en la matière oui
justement tout à l'heure on évoquait
effectivement les aides qui pouvaient
être amenées et les propositions
effectivement d'Olivier du socle sur sur
le
maintien ou en tout cas le fait de
d'augmenter le recrutement des seniors
et on a le sentiment en fait en lisant
ces propositions que le fait d'avoir un
faible des emplois des seigneurs
viendrait des seniors en réalité nous on
considère que pour augmenter le
recrutement des seniors faudrait des
mesures incitatives auprès des
entreprises des mesures qui peuvent être
effectivement d'assouplir peut-être
l'embaucher seniors il y a des
réflexions au niveau effectivement
d'allègement de charge et puis il y a un
certain nombre de mesures effectivement
qui sont plus alors un peu plus
contraignantes type indice pour
surveiller effectivement un certain
nombre de d'indicateurs dans
l'entreprise qui permettent de faire
progresser l'emploi des seniors donc ça
c'est la première chose on est très
favorable au fait de d'améliorer le
recrutement des seniors par ces mesures
là la deuxième chose pour nous c'est de
maintenir l'employabilité des seniors et
les employeurs ont une vraie
responsabilité de maintenir
l'employabilité tout au long des
carrières pas seulement sur le poste en
cours mais en favorisant les formations
y compris en deuxième partie de carrière
et ça c'est souvent oublié en favorisant
les mobilités internes horizontales pas
seulement des promotions et ça souvent
il y a beaucoup seniors qui regrettent
d'être restés sur un poste ou alors
justement de pas bénéficier de ces
mobilités là et puis la troisième partie
qui me paraît essentielle c'est la
partie culturelle il faut déconstruire
les stéréotypes il faut former en
entreprise ça peut pas être un problème
implicite on disait tout à l'heure nous
au centre de la compétence égale on
s'intéresse à tous les types de
discrimination étonnamment celui contre
les seniors il est souvent oublié ou
alors il choque moins que les autres
alors que on est tous potentiellement
concernés et on a un vrai besoin de
déconstruire l'extéréotypes et les
stéréotypes voilà enfin on a le
stéréotype effectivement de la carrière
ascendante la femme la natation
technologique on en a parlé tout à
l'heure le fait qu'un senior va bientôt
partir en stress alors qu'en réalité la
durée moyenne en poste dans une
entreprise c'est beaucoup réduite donc
c'est pas un problème et puis on a aussi
vraiment besoin de former les managers
au management intergénérationnel c'est
pas quelque chose qui s'est
naturellement en France on a un gros
retard sur nos voisins sur le sujet donc
il faut vraiment vraiment que les
entreprises se saisissent de ce sujet
est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi un une part
de je sais pas que le terme employé mais
on parle de de finalement de notre
culture d'entreprise d'auto dénigrement
du Seigneur par lui-même vous voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est à dire que c'est
tellement rentré dans les dans les dans
nos habitudes ou dans notre perception
de du vieux que on se dit alors ça y est
j'ai 51 ans j'ai 52 ans je vois plus
rien et je peux pas je peux pas le
vendre soit une autre entreprise soit
soit changer de job dans mon entreprise
reflète l'image qu'on lui renvoie donc
c'est cette image et justement elle est
très française quand même il y a un
agissement
en France beaucoup plus prononcé
qu'ailleurs et le deuxième point c'est
que je pense qu'on a pas compris en
France qu'on a été dans une société de
longévité et que donc le il n'y a pas
que vieillissement nous on pense que
vieillissement
c'est l'horreur donc il faut réduire les
risques du vieillissement et c'est pour
ça qu'on dit les retraites etc mais non
réduire les risques de vieillissement
c'est la dépendance et les retraites
vous avez tous vu qu'on avait pas de loi
grand âge et la retraite aux va la
repousser mais c'est pas ça c'est
optimiser les nouvelles ressources
de ces personnes quand elles avancent en
âge parce qu'elles ont des ressources
les seniors aujourd'hui ils ont des
compétences et je vous donne l'exemple
parce que je disais c'est plus
âgé autour de cette dame
les seniors ont des compétences donc il
faut optimiser ces nouvelles ressources
pour le pays pour l'entreprise pour le
pays et c'est ça qu'on ne fait pas on ne
fait pas du tout optimiser les
compétences c'est ouvrir un horizon en
emploi dans cet argument je voudrais
reprendre ce que Quentin nous disait
tout à l'heure là ceux qui sont en haut
de la en haut du classement en Europe
les pays du Nord à la Suède 76,9% des 50
64 ans en emploi Norvège 74-6 Danemark
72 et quel qu'est-ce qu'ils font mieux
que nous
alors c'est culturel vous allez me
répondre mais mais au-delà de ça
c'est trop vague il y a à la fois bon
d'abord c'était des sociétés qui pendant
très longtemps étaient des sociétés très
très cohésives avec plutôt des modèles
assez des modèles d'engagement citoyen
des modèles de syndicalisme c'est pas un
hasard si ce sont des pays qui ont des
taux de syndicalistes très élevés il y
avait aussi
il y a eu aussi toute une série de
politiques des politiques de l'emploi
des politiques économiques qui ont aidés
de la croissance alors enfin je voudrais
quand même rappeler que si en France on
a un aussi mauvais taux d'emploi des
seniors c'est aussi parce que on a
engrangé des années et des années de
chômage massif et des difficultés à
créer des emplois et quand on crée peu
d'emplois en fait les premiers qu'il les
prennent c'est d'abord ceux qui sont au
début de la file d'attente c'est les
jeunes voir ceux qui sont bien formés et
pour les plus âgés ce qu'ont le plus de
difficultés alors plus âgé attention 45
50 ans à partir de là parce que c'est
quand même ça que donc les moments où en
fait ou les les vagues de recrutement
sont moins importante mais en fait c'est
là où on a moins de possibilités de
trouver un emploi donc
c'est ça qui explique que ces pays-là
aillent aussi bien bon le cas de
Royaume-Uni est un peu différent et
après quand vous prenez la Finlande
l'Allemagne c'est des pays qui qui ont
mis en place des mesures notamment avec
de la négociation sectorielle et qui
sont aussi dans un contexte quand même
démographique pas du tout le même que la
France c'est-à-dire avec une population
qui est plutôt un peu contenue voire en
décroissance donc il y a toute une série
d'éléments qui jouent et c'est pas juste
l'âge de la retraite je dirais plutôt
que l'âge de la retraite qu'on se permet
d'avoir c'est celui qui reflète les
conditions dans lesquelles on est donc
la Suède par exemple on est aujourd'hui
à ils ont augmenté à 60 de l'âge minimum
c'est-à-dire l'âge auquel on peut
commencer à prendre sa retraite et ils
ont monté là le maximum à 67 l'âge pivot
c'est 65 c'est l'âge de la pension
garantie par l'État mais il faut savoir
que de plus en plus au fil des
générations de plus en plus de
ça me gêne pas de rentrer et d'avoir une
échéance la seule chose qui m'intéresse
c'est la garantie de mon taux plein
et aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas un modèle
de contrat de travail qui vous permet de
jouer là dessus je pense que ça ça
répondrait beaucoup plus on mesure
purement financière le gouvernement sont
utiles mais cette partie là Crète ça
casserait un peu de logique culturelle
merci beaucoup merci à tous je vais
rappeler le titre de votre livre de l'un
de vos livres Anne-Marie Guimard
allongement de la vie quelle difficulté
politique c'est aux éditions de la
découverte il y a aussi les défis du
vieillissement âge emploi retraite c'est
chez Armand Colin voilà je vous dis à
demain 18h 22h et puis votre prochain
rendez-vous politique l'invité politique
de la matinale rien de Mancini reçoit
Éric Coquerel le président elle est
fille de la commission des finances à
l'Assemblée belle soirée
[Musique]